let's move on to the next topic we want
to talk about and it kind of Lee of
course that each one leads into the
other right we want to talk about again
this this is I think this one is the
elephant in the room
um because just recently I had my kids
you know in a camp here in Tobago and
this issue came up with somebody the the
other kids talking to I was you know a
non-muslim you know uh Muslims are not
Muslims of course
and they were asking my daughters you
know how do you guys meet someone to get
married to if you don't date there's no
free mixing of the Sexes as a matter of
fact Islam doesn't even allow for demand
and the woman to touch us our Prophet
Muhammad peace be upon Him says he says
the man and the woman the the prophet
sallam himself never touched a
non-family member woman uh himself so
and and because these things invoke a
type of sexuality we could all attest to
that those of us who grew up in the west
we know that so if we if we're not
mixing with the other sex and we're not
having that sort of you know interaction
with the opposite sex and gender
um how is it that we meet women and how
do we meet men for example how do we get
married and what how does Islam go about
doing that is that something that you
know uh can you elaborate a bit on it
there's a myth that
love is
something that arises from you know
superficiality you know just outward
appearances and that sort of thing
and that love is something that comes uh
just intuitionally you know that you
just have a feeling about a person
love at first sight and the scholars
have discussed this in great detail I've
been who has a has a book and what this
has been talked about in great detail
you know this notion of Romanticism and
it does exist it does exist right but to
say that all love is like that is a
fallacy as a fallacy right and even
hazim himself and is
discusses that in great detail
um
that you know some people are quick to
love and they're they're quick to fall
in love and quick to fall out of love
some people are slow to fall in love but
yet they build a family together to the
end of it right so love has its causes
that there is a natural Affinity between
people that there's there's a shared
commonality that they like the way each
other look and they like the
personalities of each other they like
the personalities of each other this is
a very simple recipe and the head of the
personality is a person's religious
beliefs and their attitude towards
religion and that sort of thing so
one
we
look at this General simple recipe of
love right then as Muslims we raise our
children
to be marriageable to have you know to
to care about their appearance to care
about the functioning of the house right
to care about the uh you know
the Aesthetics of the house and the you
know you know for for men the ability to
earn and provide for family and to have
the grit and resilience that's needed to
face the challenges that are going to
come and adulthood we prepare as we
talked about adolescence and this is at
the core of Western Society especially
in today's world you know that
adolescence is focused upon and was
really invented you know around 150
years ago as a concept and adulthood was
kind of you know went away from a tossed
side so right you know to look at
how to raise our children to be
marriageable and to be prepared for the
challenges of adulthood you know to go
through um to have the skills and the
virtues and the values that are
necessary to face the hardships of life
you know that make a family cement it
together and give people longevity in
their relationship and for people to
know the rights of each other you know
through the teachings of the religion
right these things have been focused on
in great detail more than any other
religion and by far you know beyond
what's in any other religion and so you
know you find a person outside of that
that their sexual relationships are
purely transactional and purely
transactional there's no unspoken
contract even let alone a written
contract between them about the
expectations that they have from each
other and the rights that are binding
upon one another and that sort of thing
and for that reason we find the erosion
of the family structure and we find that
this usually that this has come for
Generations from the top echelons of
society
right this non-judgmentalism and that
you know you know sold your Royal oats
and you know go and you know live you
know your wildest you know fantasies and
then you know once you reach your late
uh 20s or mid-30s then settle down with
some poor unsuspecting person who you
know who you know didn't know what you
went through or has a similar background
you know you know who you know doesn't
have who's not ready for marriage and
not ready for Parenthood and so on and
so forth and you know we see the effects
of this at the bottom echelons of
society we see the effects of this in
the street culture and the drug culture
and the Gang culture and all these sorts
of things
and it's a very selfish way
to approach looking at starting a family
and starting the Next Generation and
that sort of thing
and the effects of that are obvious to
anybody who will take the blinders off
and take you know the the horse blinders
often the rose-colored glasses and just
look at it for what it is